today january the 27th also marks
international holocaust remembrance day
right around the globe
people are paying their respects and
remembering the victims of nazi
atrocities
in which some 6 million jewish people
died
however a recent poll in the uk has
suggested a growing number of people are
unaware of the holocaust or simply deny
that it happened well to discuss this
i'm joined on the program by ephraim
zuroff the director of the
israeli office for the simon weisenthal
center
on eastern european affairs we
appreciate
your take on this day the
holocaust remembrance day of course a
recent poll as we've been talking about
has suggested around 2.6 million britons
are
denying the holocaust that's the
equivalent of one in 20 uk
adults how shocked are you by that
figure
i think it's quite it's quite shocking
and surprising
but it's not the only problematic figure
in this
in this survey in other words you have
five percent to deny
eight percent too uh convinced that the
numbers are exaggerated
20 percent think that the number is less
the number of victims is less than
2 million and 45 percent don't even know
so i think you're combining uh
anti-semitism uh with abysmal ignorance
it is a startling number and it's not
only the uk according to
to other polls what are the consequences
if fewer people are actually aware of
the holocaust
well the basic idea behind holocaust
education is that
the tragedy that we call the holocaust
has lessons for humanity
about the dangers of hatred the dangers
of anti-semitism
racism fascism and obviously
we think that it's important that people
study the holocaust to learn
from that tragedy and to try in that
manner to prevent the recurrence of such
a tragedy
when you look at that figure 1 in 20 uk
adults not believing that the holocaust
actually took place at all
what do you put that down to it that's
not the figure it's not one
uh one in 20 right 120 uk uk adults
and 2.6 million britons right and what
do you put
how do you put it down to a frame a rise
of nationalism
across europe or at least an increase in
that
what has your center found out
let's make one thing clear holocaust
denial
is simply a new form of anti-semitism
the holocaust is the most documented
tragedy in human history
there are millions i repeat millions of
documents
that prove the crimes of the holocaust
there's no
basis for this denial it's totally
absurd
so why do people do it it's basically a
new form of anti-semitism
because imagine what would happen if it
turns out that
the holocaust did not happen obviously
that would be a very bad situation for
the jewish people all over the world
you know at the same time most people
would be hard pushed to give factual
details about other
genocides today is also the the 25th
anniversary
of the occurrence in rwanda when
millions of people died
when you look at such a thing could it
be down a lot of this to a simple lack
of knowledge
listen it's not only a question of
knowledge it's also a question of
deterrence
you know when when the camps were
liberated
in other words the camps in germany were
liberated by the british and the
americans and auschwitz was liberated by
the russians
and the world was exposed to the scope
of nazi atrocities
the phrase never again was coined and
i'm sure that the people who coined that
phrase had good intentions
and were really determined that such a
thing would never happen again
but on the other hand so many tragedies
have occurred since
that are not the holocaust thank god but
they have some similar
characteristics and the question you ask
yourself and i ask myself
is how is that possible after the
horrors of the holocaust were exposed
and i think that one of the answers or
one of the factors
that is very important to take into
account is the fact
that the number of people responsible
for these crimes
who are brought to justice is not that
large let's put it this way the
percentage is not that large
and i think when people today
contemplate joining
genocidal movements or islamic
fundamentalist movements
first question they ask themselves is
will i be caught what will happen if
i'll be caught
will i be held accountable and if you
look at the figures for the
people involved in the holocaust a
relatively small percentage of the
people who were responsible for these
crimes were actually
put on trial and punished how can
society actually go about
therefore changing the views of people
who
who'd actually deny that this happened
that six million jews were killed
in the holocaust
well it has to take place on two
different levels one level is the level
of leadership
that the leaders of the world the
leading political leaders in every
country
have to make clear that this is a fact
that this happened
and this has very important consequences
for their country as well
and then there's the question of the
educational systems in other words
this is subject that has to be taught in
the in the school curriculum
at the proper age and to be done
effectively
and with the best technological and
other
educational aids you feel that's not
happening in schools enough just finally
now listen there's no question that it's
happening in many schools all over the
world
and there's someone who gives lectures
at yad vashem the israeli national
memorial
to hundreds of teachers every year who
come from all over the world to teach
the holocaust
there's no question that some very
excellent holocaust education
is taking place but it's almost
impossible to reach everybody
and the figures that you presented on
from this survey about the uk
clearly show that and i suppose you know
when you look at those figures is that
the younger generation simply being
ignorant
about this frame because there's a lot
of things when you look into details
about history
they simply do not know the facts of and
this is something that needs to be
pressed home
particularly younger stage in education
would you agree with that
listen it should not be pressed home at
two younger stage
that's a different problem in other
words it has to be started
uh in the let's say eighth grade or
ninth tenth grades
not but not before that in other words
you don't want to scare these kids
out of their minds and it's not
appropriate so
this has to be done in a proper manner
at the bright age
in the right way and this is a this is
really a challenge a tremendous
challenge to the educational systems
in countries all over the world but i
have to say that many people are taking
up this challenge and many people
are doing an excellent job and that's
why many people
are knowledgeable about the holocaust by
the way one thing that's not clear
is the ages of those people who deny the
holocaust right
the ages of the people who think
veterans who are not sure that
six million were murdered or people
underestimate said that's not clear from
this survey
yeah thank you so much though for coming
today on the program i'm explaining all
that on
this day holocaust memorial day we've
been speaking to a frame zero off
director of the israeli office for this
simone weissenthal
center and eastern european affairs go
ahead
let me allow me to allow me to correct
you sure
today is not the anniversary of the 25th
anniversary of the genocide in rwanda
that genocide started in april not in
january no absolutely but it's being
marked by a lot of people in london
today but thank you so much for for
giving us your thoughts today sir
you